the question must therefore be
considered whether in a sense certainty
itself the object is in fact the kind of
essence that sense certainty for claims
it to be whether this notion of it as
the essence corresponds to the way it is
present and since certainty to the end
we have not only to reflect on it and
ponder what it might be a truth but only
to consider the way in which it is
present in sense certainty
in Section 94 which is a very short
passage Hegel is is saying look now we
need to actually formulate our question
we need to think about how we're going
to ask this that's important to figure
out exactly what you're asking about
and then how we'll go about resolving
that question what should we do what
shouldn't we do so really the question
that that are there questions that are
being explored here and that are going
to be grappled with in the rest of this
this cent certainty section are these
how is the object really present in
sense certainty what's really going on
when were perceiving something through
our senses as immediate as just what it
is how does that really work
is it the way that like I put here and
follow-up question is it really the way
that since certainty says that it is you
know that sense certainties pretense is
that I'm just giving you the thing as as
it is I'm not adding anything to it
you're not adding anything to it you're
getting the straight thing unadulterated
pure just experiential is that really
what's going on when we're having that
kind of relation of knowledge to an
object now hitting goal is going to
frame this a little bit more precisely
by saying does the notion of it as
essence so does the grip the concept
what we're able to work out as were
thinking our way through this as we're
following out the twists and turns of
what reveal themselves to us in in sense
certainty does the notion of it as
essence that is the object as what is
most real as impinging upon us as sort
of giving itself in its full
concreteness and its true reality to us
the perceivers
is that does that really correspond to
how it is in sense certainty or have we
made a mistake
are we misrepresenting to ourselves the
way sense certainty works this is quite
important because what he's attacking
here it is you might say the imaginary
element in empiricism empiricists and
you know people who appeal to common
sense are quite often saying look things
just are the way they are you just kind
of take a min you're not actually adding
at anything to them unless you're biased
or or you're filtering things out but if
you're ready to just take it in as it is
then there's nothing that that you're
you know changing in it Hegel's saying
well I don't know but that's actually
the case why don't we look at sense
certainty see what goes on and see
whether it measures up to its own
pretensions now he does counsel
something that's quite important here at
the end of it he says we have to reflect
on it and ponder what it might be in
truth we can't do an armchair analysis
of this where we just kind of think what
is it like to have a sensory experience
we have to have some basis upon which to
work so there is a kind of empiricism
going on here but it's an empiricism
that's more radical than the typical
empiricism even the ones that call
themselves radical empiricism he says we
have to consider the way in which it
really is present in sense certainty so
we need to look at how sense or new
worse
it is that innocence certainty itself
that must be asked what is the this if
we take the this in the twofold shape
that's being as now and as here the
dialectic it has in it will receive a
form as intelligible as that this itself
is to the question what is now let us
answer for example now it's night in
order to test the truth of this sense
certainty a simple experiment will
suffice we write down this truth a truth
cannot lose anything by being written
down any more than I can lose anything
through our preserving it if now this
new and we look again at the written
truth we shall have to say that it has
become stable
in section 95 Hegel is going to actually
ask sense certainty what's going on here
tell me about how the object actually is
really what do you make of this what is
the fist what is the object that you say
is so independent is the essential thing
that the eye doesn't really matter that
knowledge is merely of the object well
what is this this and it arrives in a
sort of doubled form and this makes
sense when we think about the ways in
which we perceive things in general we
perceive now at this time of course it's
rather difficult and we're going to see
that you can't actually hold on to it
now and then in space here not over
there but here when we're having an
experience it's presenting it to us in
this sort of you know supposedly
unmediated
way we're conscious of the the now and
here we say that we're present in the
moment at the moment includes both you
know spatial and temporal sort of
dimension to them but then we can ask
that's fine
what's now now notice what yeah it has
to happen since certainty has to specify
something about them now and also it's
going to have to specify something about
the here so you know we could pick
anything we want we could say that well
the the time itself determines it and so
it imposes itself upon us but you know
we can also sort of in our imagination
say well let's pick five o'clock or 10
o'clock or you know make up whatever we
want Hegel goes with night now is night
it's been in fact as I'm recording that
that's not the case but perhaps while
you're watching that that is the case
and here's where we get to what's really
important in this
he says in order to test the truth of
this sad certainty I notice what he's
doing we're taking that certainty to
this height and we want to test the
truth of it you might said well why why
would you test the truth of certainty I
mean what it means to be certain about
something is you don't need to test the
truth because you already know that it's
true you're certain of it oh no you're
not because if you really were then you
wouldn't be so defensive when somebody
says how can you be certain of your
certainty how do you know that your
certainty is true that defensiveness is
itself a sort of effective correlate to
an epistemological problem how do we
know the truth of sense certainty we say
that it's not and we can test it so he
says we write down this truth the truth
could not lose anything by being written
down we've written it down right here
right it's being imposed through pixels
on your screen whatever it is that
you're watching this about we weren't
down this truth the truth can out
there's anything being written down any
more than it can lose anything through
our preserving it through our
remembering it through our keeping it
going in language if now this knew and
we look again at the written truth what
happens is it night right now if it's
new it's not so this doesn't have a
truth anymore and what's really
interesting about this passage Hegel
doesn't say oh yeah now it's just become
false truth is just the correlate to
falsity and it's true fluctuates back
and forth you know sort of look the
example of a broken watch is Right twice
a day because it's going to sooner or
later wind up at that point he says that
this truth has now become stale it's
become shawl it's become outworn
it's become out
and it no longer works for us it's
insipid so what's going on here notice
what Hagel has done he's forced us to
specify in sense certainty just what the
this is supposed to be now we're stuck
with it now and here and whenever women
now we have to pick a particular now and
that makes us a bit vulnerable to that
now no longer being what it was that we
thought it was and we're doing this just
by unpacking what's going on in Scent
certainty
the now that is night is preserved that
is in its treated as what it professes
to be as something that is but it proves
itself to be on a country something that
is not the now does indeed preserve
itself but is something that is not
night equally it preserves itself in the
face of the day that it now is as
something also that is not day in other
words as a negative in general this
self-preserving now is therefore not
immediate but mediated for it is
determined as a permanent and
self-preserving now through the fact
that something else that is day at night
is not and so determined it is still
just as simply now as before and in the
simplicity is indifferent to what
happens in it just as little as day and
night are its being just as much also is
it date and night it is not in the least
affected by this it's other being a
simple thing of this kind which is
through negation which is neither this
nor that a not this and it is with equal
and difference this as well as that such
a thing we call a universal so it is in
fact the universal that is the true
content of set certainty
in Section 96 we're arriving at another
critical juncture where we're going to
get the introduction of the universal so
let's see how we actually get there
again we're watching to see what happens
with instant certainty when we
interrogate it about how it actually
plays out you know when you're dealing
with here or a now what does that
determinately mean for the consciousness
that's supposed to be purely immediate
so if we think about the preservation
that's going on of the night that no
longer exists because now it's day Hagel
says that the novel that is night is
preserved it is it is kept in play it's
treated as what it professes to be as
something that is so we have now is
night is something that is in a certain
sense but we know that that's not
actually the whole story notice that I
didn't say not actually the case just
not the whole story
because it's also something that is not
because it is day so now is night and
that's preserved in a certain way and
now is also not night because it's day
and we can change the the polarities if
we want we can change it today and say
that day does the same thing when it
goes to night time or when it's Twilight
or whatever you want to bring it up so
where do we go from here
he says the now does preserve itself
here's where a key transition is taking
place the now preserves itself but it's
something that is not night equally it
preserves itself in the face of the day
that it now is as something that also is
not day now is greater than night or day
now it could be either one of them
and it can go back and forth so now is
actually something that is different
from night and is different from day and
here we get into some really interesting
logic you might say well it's gotta be
one or the other no it doesn't could be
dawn well dawn is part of day well you
know if you want to quibble that sort of
thing we can always keep introducing
more and more distinctions and you're
still gonna wind up with the same
problem even if you added in three
possibilities or ten possibilities you'd
have the same dialectic taking place so
he said he says it's not night and it's
not day in other words it is a in
general so what we took to be pure
determinacy now what could be more
concrete than now turns out to be a
negation it turns out to be something
negative turns out to be something
that's almost empty just waiting for
content to fill it even Anthony says
that self-preserving now is not
immediate but mediated for it is
determined as a permanent insult
preserving now we'll look at that in a
moment so determinant is a self
preserving now through the fact that
something else is not so this is a
mediation this is a mediation but now as
a negation possesses more being or is
more essential than either one of these
two determinate qualities or quantities
or you know whatever you want to call
them whatever modality you want to
ascribe to them so he says the
self-preserving now is a permanent and
self-preserving now through the fact
that some
is not and so determined it is just as
simply now as before and this simplicity
is indifferent to what happens in it so
it can contain Danny or it can contain
night but it doesn't care because it's
going to remain now just as much when
it's day as when it's not it doesn't
really matter as far as the now is
concerned what content you want to show
in there it'll continue being me this
this now forever it is purely simple
let's go on
so you says just as little as day and
night are it's being just as much also
is it day and night so there's something
paradoxical being said here day and
night are not the being of now nor are
say noon and midnight or you know any
particular hour of the day and yet it is
those things at the same time now
doesn't that strike you as a little bit
strange doesn't that seem to violate the
law of you know non-contradiction a
thing can't be and not be in the same
way at the same time or can it there's
one kind of thing that angle says does
that
a universal a universal both is the
thing of what is the things of which it
is a universal and it is not them
it relates itself to them in a way that
both negates them and unfolds them into
itself that allows them to be the
content for it and says you're not the
whole show I'm not the main show I'm the
thing that gives you what you are you
contribute mere determinacy I contribute
assets I contribute the what it is to be
what you are so he goes on and he says a
simple thing of this kind which is
through negation which is neither in
this case this nor that I not this and
it is with equal indifference also this
and that such a thing we call the
universal so what do we have here since
certainty was supposed to be about
concrete things it was supposed to be
about the immediate experience not about
universals but this shows us that the
truth of self certain of a sense
certainty is indeed the universal that's
what sense certainty really is providing
us with when we start digging down into
it and paying attention to what's going
on
it is as a universal that we utter what
the sensuous content is when what we say
is this that is the universal of this or
it is that is being in general of course
we do not an envisage the universal this
or being in general but we honor the
universal in other words we do not
strictly say what in the sense certainty
we mean to say but language as we see is
the more truthful in it we ourselves
directly refute what we mean to say and
since the universal is the true content
of sense certainty and language
expresses this true content alone it is
not it is just not possible for us ever
to say or express in words a sensuous
being that we mean
immediately after hitting us with this
realization that cent certainty involved
something that we didn't think that it
did namely the universal which seemed to
be exactly the opposite of what cent
certainty and the kind of experience and
knowledge that it promised us was all
about Hinkle is going to hit us with yet
another major revelation which is that
language is at the very heart of what's
going on here and that opposed you know
this opposition that we have here
between language is dealing at the
universal in the sense certainty is
dealing with a particular really is not
going to hold in part because language
is at the core of the truth of sense
certainty just as much as the universal
is there's a paradox a lot the paradox
Akala T to send certainty which is that
it cannot be what it promised originally
it has to be something that seems
exactly at the opposite end of the
spectrum from it but this is what
dialectical analysis shows us so he says
it is as a universal that we utter what
the sensuous content is so before we go
into the more abstract Universal this
let's think about what happens when we
are using language so we have this you
know relationship now between
consciousness the pure eye and the
object the sensuous content over here
and the relationship is one of knowledge
scent certainty is supposed to be
immediate knowledge to be seen that's
not really immediate but let's just say
that through the time being that that is
because we don't need to Kontest that
when we speak about when we express or
utter what that thing over there is like
when we said here or sad day or night as
part we say now so day or night is part
of them now later on is going to be
treaty and other things in part it's
done here as soon as we begin speaking
not just
thinking but speaking as soon as we
begin using language we are dealing with
the universal as we've seen the
universal is interesting because it is
at the same time an affirmation and a
negation of all of the particulars that
that Universal relates itself to it is
not those particulars and yet it also is
those particulars in some ways it's more
those particulars than those particulars
are themselves this is all relations of
mediation as we've just seen in previous
discussions so as soon as consciousness
begins treating the sensuous content as
something particular it also has to
universalize it in order to make sense
of it so it's not so receptive or
immediate as we originally took it to be
that's not what's going on and scent
certainty because if you can ask
somebody what are you watching what are
you looking at what do you taste and
they're able to respond with anything as
soon as they respond they're engaging
with a universal how is that chocolate
taste good sweet bitter
those are universals tastes chocolaty
that's universal what are you watching a
bunch of birds now you didn't describe
you know I see 41 Birds and they're you
know arranged in all these ways because
you can't do that in language language
works by means of universalizing of
making things less concrete more
abstract but it's through that that
we're able to have the concrete ask and
create otherwise we wouldn't be able to
understand that so let's go on now he
says what about the this the universal
this well that is in general now we're
not just talking about one thing we're
talking about beings as such we're doing
metaphysics here he says we don't
envisage the universalness or being in
general
that's a really interesting thing to
think about what is the universalness
what is being in general what does it
taste like how does it impress itself
upon you let's get away from sense
things and let's talk about feelings
what's your feeling about being we don't
have that sort of thing it's something
that we can speak something that we can
think but it's not something that we can
perceive through the senses so sense
perception since certainty has led us
away from the senses as such he says we
don't envisage the universal of this or
being in general we utter the out zaga
we utter the universal we don't strictly
say what in this sense certainty we mean
to say so language by its very nature
does tend to conceal or to distort or to
change the thing that it's trying to
express but it's the only game in town
it's the only way you are going to
express it so when somebody asks you
about the sensuous content you have to
respond in language thereby
universalizing it there by meeting it
there by changing it to a certain extent
thereby making sense certainty something
very different than what it purported to
be so he says language is actually more
truthful since certainty showed us that
it's kind of deceptive it isn't really
certainty it doesn't really provide the
most concrete truth it really leads us
into other things language though is
more truthful why we directly refute
what we mean to say and since the
universal is the true content of sense
certainty and language expresses this
true content alone it is just not
possible for us ever to see or Express
and words a sensuous being that we mean
were confronted with a limit that we
can't actually Express with universals
the universal language or thought
exactly what it is that we are
experiencing exactly what we are
perceiving as receptive
you know beings sensuously engaged with
the world of experience
we're already distorting it just by the
mere fact of naming things but like I
said that's the only game in town since
certainty it has under investigation
shown us to be the case so language is
in a certain respect more truthful
because of that it expresses insist the
universal is the true content of self
assent certainty now notice one other
thing that we're going to sort of close
with as we get ready to move into some
some even deeper discussions where have
we posed this impossibility of ever
truly saying what it is that we intend
in terms of the particular where have we
laid that problematic out I might say on
the chalkboard dr. Stadler but how have
I done that this is all language sure
there's a few you know arrows and things
like that but those are symbols as well
they're supposed to represent relations
it is in language that we are able to
represent to ourselves and grasp the
truth of the impossibility of with
language grasping the truth of the
sensuous particular which means that the
sensuous particular as such is an
abstraction that has been brought into
the realm of language into the realm of
thought into the realm of the concept
the
Magali and be Griffith what we've seen
happen here is that since certainty has
been alcohol ban it's been you you know
you can call it sublation or transcended
we're moving away from anything like a
pure sense certainty and now we're in
the realm of language